Film Courage: What would you say those
two web series did for your career?
Sujata Day, Actor, Writer/Director: The Guild
and The Awkward Black Girl put me on the map I
believe in terms of exposure even at that time I
had just done season two of Awkward Black Girl I
had just done season six of The Guild and then I
got a call from my commercial agent. At this point
I did not have a theatrical agent and they said
“Hey the casting director of Arrested Development
is coming back and the casting director wants to
offer you a small role.” I said “What? How did
they even know about me? I'm not auditioning
for TV shows or films right now?” They said
“They had been watching web series and they
just discovered me so that was getting to do
an episode of Arrested Development was
really really special and and being on a
proper television set with hair and
makeup and craft services and them
picking up my outfit and being on set with David
Cross and Alia Shawkat that was just an experience
that I will never forget because I wasn't
expecting it at the time would you say you're
here now because of those two series has your life
sort of your career the trajectory of it because
of those series the timing was right that it just
brought other great things into your life other
roles oh yeah I credit awkward black girl with
pretty much my entire career and and the path that
I personally chose to take which is creating my
own content and putting my own stuff out there and
taking risks and not sitting by the phone waiting
for it to ring waiting for my agent to call me
almost with those calls when they do come are
presents because I'm continuing to make my own
content and then when my agent does call with
something I'm oh that's cool that's surprising
and exciting so so I love that about my life and
definitely I credit everything too Awkward Black
Girl you talked about risk earlier waiting by
the phone and now that you can take chances and
a risk to create your own work but even from a
young age it sounds with the spelling bees for
however long that lasted that's a risk that was
definitely a risk especially at that time I was
a shy introverted kid so to get up in front of an
audience I remember that moment because when when
you're in class of eight and you're just doing the
spelling bee there's no audience it's just you get
your word right or wrong and if you get it wrong
you just sit and you become the audience and I
was around my friends so I do remember going to
the regionals and seeing that huge audience and
that probably scared me off as well so what I'm
just making excuses for spelling the word radish
but anyway so it because I see you as that
you have a lot of you wouldn't be fearful of
of challenges but it seems you yeah I'm not
fearful of challenges now I will say I said
I was a shy introverted kid and then in seventh
grade when I switched to public school and had all
these friends I looked in the mirror and I said to
myself I cannot be shy and introverted anymore and
then I just switched and then I was getting kicked
out of math class because I was talking too much
there was a discussion on Twitter a few weeks back
about the film Community the writing community and
the wrong way and the right way to do something
and I just wondered what your thoughts are on that
is there a wrong way to make a movie is there a
right way you talked about over the course of the
pandemic you made watching movies sort of your
film school but there is a dogma of this is the
right way to do something the right way to enter a
scene to end a scene do you feel that or everyone
should have their own unique style I don't feel
there's a right or a wrong way I think there are
greats that have come before us that we can learn
a lot from and they all have their own Styles and
if you're watching something David Lynch and Twin
Peaks you notice that he he tends to break the
rules and and go into melodrama which was the best
part about Twin Peaks I just loved it so much but
then you then you watch something Good Fellas and
that feels what a film buff would say is the right
way to make a movie but but I think I I just
love all kinds of movies and especially if you
watch International films if you watch something
that I'm really inspired by is sethiji thrai who
is a Bengali filmmaker I'm also Bengali and he
won an honorary Oscar in the 80s or the 90s and
he what he did was he kind of broke off well he
didn't want to make Bollywood type movies which
is what Indian India was known for at the time
and he just went into the villages and started
focusing on women in The Villages and and
he would write these amazing stories about
just regular women and what they were going
through and and it wasn't about being rich
and it wasn't about musical dance numbers and
and it was just a quiet story and so what I
believe is there's not a right or wrong way to do
or create art and I think what's exciting to me is
when you do get out of those boxes and and we
were talking about risk when you take a risk
and and maybe it doesn't pan out the way that
you wanted to in this project then you don't do
it again in the next one you take a different
kind of risk and I love when projects surprise
me I love it when they go a certain way or do a
certain thing that I'm not expecting and that's
what's exciting to me about art which movies and
TV shows fall into as well has anyone said that
to you this should be more this if you if you do
it more this way it'll have more marketability
I believe that happens more in the screenwriting
process and not really in the filmmaking process
I I get notes from my scripts and my pitches
and honestly most of the time the notes are
make the project better so it allows me to
think about the project in a different way
that I may not have seen before and and that's
what's really exciting sometimes what happens
is you'll go through a circle of notes taking you
back to that same place where you started but now
you're more clear about why you started with
that story so it's I appreciate notes I love
getting very hard critical notes on my work
and and I won't necessarily take 100 of the
notes but each note allows me to think about
the scene or my characters or the work in a
different way so I'm okay where is this now
coming from what is the person not attached
onto what what are they not getting in
this part and that's where the actual
note is coming from so getting notes to me is
very very awesome because generally every time
I've gotten notes and I've done the rewrite it's
a better script than what I had written before
did anybody give you notes with definition please
can you make it go more in this direction and then
we'll have more marketability for it because
it's really just a story about coming being a
young person whether you want to leave the
nest or stay in your small town it doesn't
have to be Bollywood it was just an experience
that happened to be different cultures that
all came together and knew each other from high
school yeah I got the I got one note that I got
I believe it was during the script process
was someone needs to die it needs to be
in this climax moment one of the family members
needs to die and I was I don't think so I don't
think that needs to happen I'm really just
trying to make it a slice of life and this
could be any family it just happens to be a South
Asian American family in the center of it all and
that's what was exciting to me just to show Indian
Americans as normal people just everyone else
I think mostly when I when I soft pitched it
around to production companies that I already had
relationships with they all said that it was too
small of a film for them to take on without really
giving me any notes in terms of oh if you made
it this maybe we could we could shoot it but I
understood that pass or that that rejection per se
because because it is a small film and it's about
there's no explosions and there's no big special
effects or anything so it's not one of the five
Studio films that that a big Studio would make
but I I wanted to make this for myself just to
just to get a story out there that I had
never seen before on screen do you see that
ever though in the film industry or with with
film and TV writing screenwriting that there's
there's definite this is the wrong way this is the
right way I think there is definitely a formula to
telling big budget films so if you're writing
a big budget film for a studio then there is
absolutely a correct way to do that and I don't
know if you guys have read Thomas Lennon's book
called how to write movies and make profit how
to make movies how to make movies for fun and
for Fun and Profit and fun is crossed out and
one of the first one of the first things that
he says in the book is if you're making a movie
for Sundance you need to put this book down
and gives really explicit instructions on how to
write and create a studio film and I just love
the book because I have applied it to my indie
films that aren't necessarily Studio films but
but it's also a really easy read and it's
funny and it's fun to get through and it's
awesome to hear his experiences and stories as
a studio screenwriter as opposed to me who's
who's writing for indie films but but yes I do
believe that there is a correct way to write a
studio film with certain beats and certain
explosions in certain moments that happen
between the stars of the film that you have to
have in there or also stars won't do the film.